[Music]
in let it all out news that's what I'm
doing
Wow submitted by I am NOT mafia yeah you
are the Jonas Brothers had such an
intense group therapy session they had
to drink to get through it
what's happening with them how old are
they how do people know about this isn't
there supposed to be some type of
confidentiality patient-doctor thing one
of the Jonas Brothers is married to
[ __ ] stay engaged right yes that's a
sophie Turner
yep we're back right here can you
introduce me to a celebrity that isn't
mentally [ __ ] they're all famous I beg
to differ
[Laughter]
that's a cool style I could never wear
that because they will get covered in
mustard or some that's true boys do this
style of the night oh my as always guys
don't only have that many options it
could be all red yeah so no one's done
that yeah it's called a blood soften if
I stop all purpose runners in the middle
green in the Miller Street I wouldn't
recognize me the one from Jumanji you
wouldn't recognize I owe you the Jonas
Brothers yeah which ones that one that's
Nick I was I did a thing with Nick Jonas
he threw pineapples at me and I chipped
my tooth in Vietnam what going down a
little really long waterslide is that
when you solve a golf what's his fix
yeah it was the front of my front tooth
and I had to put you know that he hurt
you and well it wasn't it was actually
his fault it was like he was throwing
pineapples at me and I was going on the
water side and one at the end of the
water side it goes up like this and
shoots you out and you're supposed to
catch the pineapple is asking if you had
some communication with him oh yeah we
definitely all talked to him but it
wasn't his fault that I chipped my tooth
it was the waters true to suitum house I
was going down my bottom to hit my top
two
I was still turn to catch the pineapple
every YouTube a sneaky if you were if
you just sued his ass you would not even
be here right who's wondering like what
kind of game do people just nope ein
Apple that's like one of the most
dangerous fruits ever that's yeah what
was a rubber pineapple that's like
playing dirty and catch
I like your clickbait started the story
oh it just sounds my - throwing
pineapples at me [ __ ] me fix your teeth
by kissing you yes yes and I was like oh
I forgot I'm married I actually didn't
know who he was like I knew who Nick
Jonas was but I didn't know what he
looked like
save you that's what idiots mean when
you say to him are they a pop group any
word so now they are they're releasing a
new album but before so they broke up
back in 2013
how can brother is break it disbanded
well they're just still brothers but
they're just not singing together just
not they're still related they wanted to
create something on their own and that
they were just trying to force it they
were just going through the motions
without the heart of it and then the way
that they communicated to each other
wasn't healthy anymore so before
recording their new album they decided
that they need it to talk things out the
author's resentment in this family yeah
remember that time when you [ __ ] that
groupie you know it's hard working with
family members man cuz like we were yeah
like that we were I was just having this
conversation today you [ __ ] gotta
find what your family member no but it's
just hard like you always have to
sugarcoat [ __ ] you know cuz there's like
the long history of things so you know
that's why we get it two arguments David
cuz you know like one of you you hurt
their feelings of [ __ ] yeah you gotta be
like careful yeah could be a thousand
times harder to you guys I got to be
delicate to Jess that's true that's very
cool this is very good and I forget and
she's the same way and she forgets and
when were business mode we hurt each
other's feelings I've been learning to
do better white life oh that's nice give
me one like for example you look pretty
today there was a fan that came out to
be and he goes hey now this is what
originally this is what normal Dame is
so it's a oh he goes I want to do a
video with you it'd be dope if we could
do and and normal
like absolutely not that's not know you
would say absolutely [ __ ] not yeah
that's something like that but what I
said was like sure one day and I gave
him a pat on the [ __ ] you're a liar
you've been giving that kid some hope
doesn't do anything for me they're gonna
watch this now so maybe it's so one day
like what if he blows up and he's like
really funny and he's like a really
funny comedian and then they end up
working together
Mike chose me well it wouldn't matter to
and he said maybe one day yeah it
would've mattered to me because that
another person's faman they're doing
well it doesn't make me still want to
work with no I know but like you could
end up in a collaborative feast together
not like you he's on your side David not
you being thirsty like you used the suck
bro but not a respect to work I had a
conversation with somebody recently
where they they wrote something for me
right and basically it did well or
whatever and he sold it to a major
Network as I mentioned to me and he kind
of said in kind of a backhanded way but
I understand why he was a little salty
cuz I said I didn't like it and he goes
well we got picked up I bet you wish you
would have done the character now I was
like no could your script is still trash
good he said that to me was very rude
yeah he doesn't change the fact I didn't
like your script ya know what I mean
just cuz I got picked up doesn't mean I
still want to be in it you've done that
right you know but you know people like
this cuz well that white light didn't
work there huh yeah I did it I'm sorry I
told you I'm trying I'm learning it for
you learning at least you're aware I
prevent things from happening I just
don't get into those situations Oh with
the fan no with people trying to work
with you no no no no like people try to
like talk to you kind of make a motive
you know let things also because of my
personality the videos that I make and
so a lot of people they see this like
online personality and they try to
one-up it yeah diva's do yeah I'm not
like that you know so it's like if you
all like date you attract smart asses
yeah and it's like but they're trying to
be a smartass for no [ __ ] reason
there's no context to it like we're just
having a normal conversation and it just
blindsides me out of nowhere and then
for me you go here I'm gonna go [ __ ]
here I mean there's no like oh you do a
little bit of this I guess I'll do a
little bit of that ya know it's here you
start it I'm an ended [ __ ] hero so
that's just kind of what happens with
these conversation I think it's just
because my online personnel is very
brash it was kind of harsh so
you think what the Jonas Brothers did
during their therapy session so what
they did is that they wrote down they
each wrote down five questions that they
wanted to ask each other on paper and
then they took turns picking a question
to answer out of a bowl
David put your phone on airplane mode it
is on airplane Louis not anyway so then
after answering that question the other
two brothers would rate the honesty of
the response on a scale of one to ten
ten being the worst
and then that score would dictate how
many seconds the other brother had to
drink for it whoa yeah that is more than
the two the headline it said that the
Jonas Brothers had such an intense group
I thought lightning to get through it I
thought it was like like you know you're
drinking because like a casual drink not
like it's raining or you did for five
seconds now I wonder what type of
therapy this is I've never heard of it
it's like it's bar therapy yeah get
together get drunk and talk about em it
worked and they really got through it
what if you don't remember anything that
you said while you were drunk well I
guess yeah it makes sense to me because
they say like the drunk person is way
more honest like they're right yeah
drunk mind speaks to sober hearts I
don't know because when I'm when I'm
drunk I'm a lot more nicer than I should
be maybe that's where you are on the
inserting inside so that must mean I'm a
bomb etre you are a vomiter though I am
a vomiter are that's one thing I think
if I could drink I would be able to bond
a little bit like a lot of people that's
a normal human social thing like you
kind of get together and drink beers and
then you start crying about your
girlfriends together right I already do
it without alcohol yeah but you know
like that's a that's a way that a lot of
people connect and bond do you know they
have lactaid for electus intolerant what
if they came up with something for
alcohol intolerant people I don't want
things that make me feel good what the
[ __ ] I'm just saying so you can connect
like what you were just saying I need to
do I need to be a Buddhist and learn how
to do that without alcohol uh I'm just
working on baby steps I just need to
learn how to sleep straight they're not
be good
that's all you're so mean oh yeah he's
irritated I'm the baby that's irritated
because I'm sleep-deprived and he's
hungry both of those things can [ __ ]
Apple is me
people need to [ __ ] talk about how
they really feel a lot more because a
lot of people to be living lies and [ __ ]
yeah cuz when people like come up and go
I love your show you guys the whole not
the back and I'm like what no but are
you talking about we have a lot back
this is harsh you know what it is we
talking about things that a lot of
people are too embarrassed to talk about
but then we hold back on things that
personal personal that like maybe other
people would regularly talk about I
don't know and there's words that we
don't use cuz the society's gonna take
it a certain way even though you'll have
that intention
yeah like the worst like [ __ ]
beautiful right those words you never
why would you say that Dave even cut
that out sighs exactly do cut network
yeah we're not known to be positive
toward each other you can't do that yeah
it's very on that's [ __ ] up you know
something's wrong if someone's being
positive to you in this group if someone
starts giving you compliments you're
like what's what are you gonna [ __ ]
do to me or I'm like what happened to my
face why is everyone telling me I'm
pretty yeah someone's not insulting you
in this group something's wrong
yeah well bar tells me I'm so cute I'm
like what's wrong with me why he's like
your hair so cute I'm like oh my god is
it [ __ ] up on my tip is my hair [ __ ]
up dammit what's wrong with me I'd never
insult you guys just cuz you're dead
inside and that means a lot is that
you're a white Walker oh my god that's
so cute you know that reference then
we're back to gave a throw everything
good you don't like you
okay Wow well I'm never gonna catch that
because this is the last thing yeah you
are because it doesn't matter i watch we
watch Breaking Bad like five years after
was over do you want thinking back after
you guys so talk about it every episode
do you yeah we're a lot Mickey we don't
share feelings we share talents and
things that we like things that you we
just put all of our emotions and things
that we like and we talk about that me
too but I'm not on this page with you
hurry up thinking that you like sushi i
love sushi all right we'll talk about
that but right now it's about and came
up
[Music]